-Emmanuel Daoud,
vous êtes avocat pénaliste,
spécialisé
dans le droit international.
La justice des tribunaux
et des cours internationales
s'exerce plus
aujourd'hui, ou l'impunité
a encore un bel avenir ?
-Je pense qu'elle s'exerce
davantage aujourd'hui
pour une raison simple,
c'est que les juristes,
qu'ils soient avocats,
avocates ou magistrats,
sont d'abord formés initialement
à la justice internationale
de façon plus récurrente
et plus approfondie.
Ensuite, on dit qu'on est
dans un monde global.
Si on est
dans un monde global,
on est dans une justice
globale.
On est de plus en plus
familiarisés
avec les outils
internationaux,
donc on peut,
de façon plus habituelle,
par exemple, saisir
la Cour pénale internationale
qui semble un grand machin,
mais dès lors
qu'on veut bien lire
le Statut de Rome,
on s'aperçoit rapidement
qu'on peut s'adresser
à cette juridiction
sans trop de difficultés,
en respectant, évidemment,
les règles de procédure.
Donc, les juristes aujourd'hui,
les avocats, les magistrats,
les victimes aussi
ont tendance à aller
devant les juridictions
internationales.
Alors, la lutte contre l'impunité
doit être menée,
et si les crimes
les plus graves
disparaissaient par enchantement,
on le saurait.
L'actualité montre
que ce n'est pas le cas.
-Expliquez-nous la différence
la Cour pénale internationale
et le TPI,
le Tribunal pénal international ?
-Alors, la Cour pénale
internationale,
elle a son siège
à La Haye,
et c'est la juridiction
qui est la seule juridiction
qui peut juger
des chefs d'Etat en exercice.
Le Tribunal pénal international
est un Tribunal pénal
international,
par exemple pour le Rwanda,
pour l'ex-Yougoslavie,
qui sont des créations
ad hoc.
Donc, la Cour pénale
internationale
est un siège permanent,
elle peut être saisie
en permanence
et elle a des magistrats,
des procureurs, des greffiers,
des enquêteurs,
qui peuvent être mobilisés
pour enquêter
sur les cinq continents.
-Diriez-vous que c'est
une avancée majeure,
la création de la CPI,
il y a 20 ans ?
-C'est une avancée majeure,
fondamentale,
qui a levé beaucoup d'espoirs
et qui a déçu énormément.
-En 20 ans, elle a condamné
que des seconds couteaux.
Le bilan est assez maigre,
mais en même temps,
la justice internationale
est politique.
Les Etats l'utilisent
quand ça les sert
mais l'écartent
dès qu'elle touche
leurs propres intérêts.
-Nous sommes d'accord,
et prenons l'exemple
du Conseil de sécurité.
Ni la Russie, ni les Etats-Unis...
-Ni la Chine, ni l'Inde,
ni Israël.
-Ni la Chine, ni l'Inde, ni Israël
n'ont reconnu la compétence
de la Cour pénale internationale.
Ca veut dire
qu'il y a une difficulté.
Les Etats-Unis l'ont refusée.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'ils mènent parfois
des guerres
dont la légitimité...
-Est contestable.
-Oui, ou en tout cas,
lorsqu'on bombarde
de façon systématique
des populations civiles,
ça s'appelle
un crime de guerre
ou un crime contre l'humanité
et les Etats-Unis
n'ont pas la volonté
d'être soumis
à ce type de juridiction.
-Comment on contourne
cette volonté manifeste
de ne pas coopérer
avec la justice internationale ?
-C'est ce qu'a fait
l'Ukraine.
Elle a reconnu la compétence
pour la situation
qu'elle vivait,
alors qu'elle n'avait pas
ratifié le Statut de Rome
et donc, la Cour pénale
internationale
a pu exercer sa compétence.
D'autres Etats, je crois,
12 Etats ont aussi déféré,
devant la Cour pénale
internationale,
la situation,
et la guerre commise
en Ukraine par la Russie.
Donc, il y a des moyens.
Le véritable progrès,
ou, plus exactement,
la consécration de la Cour
pénale internationale
interviendra le jour
où tous les pays...
-Reconnaîtront sa compétence.
-Reconnaîtront sa compétence,
où tous les pays
et tous les chefs d'Etat
pourront être poursuivis.
-Alors, la Cour pénale
internationale
a lancé un mandat d'arrêt
le 17 mars dernier
contre le président russe
Vladimir Poutine.
C'est la première fois
qu'un chef d'Etat en exercice,
membre du Conseil de sécurité,
est visé par une telle
procédure ?
-C'est la première fois,
lorsque nous avions saisi,
en décembre,
la Cour pénale internationale
s'agissant de la déportation
des enfants ukrainiens.
Si on l'a fait,
c'est qu'on y croyait,
mais je dois être honnête.
Nous ne pensions pas
que la Cour pénale internationale
allait réagir aussi vite.
-Oui, elle a réagi
en trois mois à peine,
c'est un temps record.
C'est une surprise pour vous.
Faut-il y voir
un signal contre l'impunité
ou une volonté
de la Cour pénale internationale
d'asseoir son autorité,
alors qu'elle est
en perte de vitesse
et de légitimité ?
-Je crois que c'est les deux,
mais ce que nous avions dit
en décembre
avec d'autres ONG
et d'autres avocats,
ce que nous avons relayé
devant la commission
des droits de l'homme
du Parlement européen,
c'était de dire : "Si vous voulez
lutter contre l'impunité
"et pour empêcher qu'on perde
la trace de ces enfants ukrainiens
"dont on ne savait pas
où ils étaient disséminés
"sur le territoire russe..."
-On parle de 400 000 enfants
arrachés à leur famille
ukrainienne,
déportés pour être adoptés
de force en Russie.
-Exactement, avec des modifications
du droit russe
qui permettaient
d'attribuer
en un temps record
à ces enfants...
-En 48 heures.
-Changer leur prénom,
changer leur nom,
changer leur lieu
de naissance,
changer leur date
de naissance...
Pour effacer les traces,
on peut pas faire mieux.
Donc, ce que l'on disait
au procureur
de la Cour pénale
internationale :
"Il faut que vous agissiez
maintenant
"pour envoyer un signal fort
"à Vladimir Poutine
et à ses sbires,
"pour qu'ils cessent
de pratiquer cette politique."
Et c'est ce qui s'est passé.
S'attaquer
à une population ciblée,
les enfants, faire en sorte
qu'ils perdent toute trace
ou tout lien biologique,
affectif, historique, culturel
avec leur nation,
avec leur pays, l'Ukraine.
Vouloir rayer ce lien
de la surface de la terre,
ça s'appelle
un crime de génocide.
Donc pour le moment,
pour que les choses
soient claires,
le mandat d'arrêt
qui a été délivré
contre Vladimir Poutine
et madame Maria Lvova-Belova
est un mandat d'arrêt
pour crimes de guerre
s'agissant de la déportation
des enfants ukrainiens.
Mais la Cour pénale internationale
est saisie de fait
et les qualifications
peuvent changer.
Le résultat,
il a été atteint.
Aujourd'hui, monsieur Poutine
est susceptible d'être arrêté
dans n'importe quel pays
qui a ratifié
le Statut de Rome.
Il est dans la situation
d'un fugitif.
C'est un délinquant
et pas autre chose.
Il peut être
à la tête d'une des nations
les plus puissantes du monde,
elle est dirigée, gouvernée
par un délinquant,
un présumé criminel,
qui est en fuite,
dans son pays,
mais qui est en fuite.
Comme signal envoyé aux despotes,
autocrates, tyrans,
aux criminels
les plus sanguinaires,
puisqu'on parle des crimes
les plus graves,
c'est un signal très fort.
Est-ce que ça va faire
disparaître les crimes...
-Les autocrates ?
-La réponse est non.
Est-ce qu'ils vont
y réfléchir à deux fois ?
Je pense que oui, et surtout,
c'est la mobilisation
des opinions publiques
internationales,
évidemment,
des médias et des avocats,
et des avocats de saisie
qui feront
demain et après-demain,
si malheureusement,
il y a des faits de cette nature
à nouveau,
qu'on pourra plus rapidement
encore intervenir
et demander à la Cour pénale
internationale
de se saisir des situations
pour qu'elle puisse
agir efficacement.
-Qu'il s'agisse
d'une politique
institutionnelle
assumée par le Kremlin,
est-ce que ça renforce,
justement,
ce chef d'inculpation de génocide ?
-Oui.
Quand on voit
que monsieur Poutine
reçoit Maria Lvova-Belova,
que celle-ci lui dit :
"On a un problème
avec les enfants ukrainiens.
"Il faut modifier notre droit
s'agissant du régime d'adoption"
que Poutine dit :
"On va s'en occuper",
et que 48 heures après,
le problème est réglé,
ça veut dire que c'est lui
qui prend les décisions.
Quand Maria Lvova-Belova dit :
- ce qu'elle ne dit plus -
"j'ai un chef, c'est Poutine",
et elle l'a pas dit une fois,
elle l'a dit 50 fois.
C'est bien que les décisions,
s'agissant de la déportation
des enfants ukrainiens
étaient prises au Kremlin.
Quand on voit que tous les moyens
militaires de transport
étaient organisés et centralisés
pour assurer ce transfert
des zones de conflit en Russie,
c'est bien qu'il y a
une volonté politique,
et une volonté politique
du Kremlin.
Et enfin, quand on voit
que l'accueil de ces enfants
est réalisé par les gouverneurs
des régions russes...
- les gouverneurs,
ça correspond à nos préfets -
et qu'à grand renfort
de médiatisation,
où tous les médias officiels
filmaient la scène
de façon très complaisante...
On voyait ces enfants à qui
on filait des peluches,
avec des familles méritantes
russes.
On disait :
"Voilà, vous avez ces enfants."
-A qui on donnait de l'argent.
-Oui, 2000 euros.
-Qui étaient indemnisées.
C'est donc une politique
pensée, réfléchie,
financée,
institutionnalisée
sur le plan logistique
et financier.
-Ce qui est fou,
c'est que ce sont les Russes
qui ont donné
tous les éléments
à charge contre eux.
-C'est incroyable.
C'est bien qu'on était
dans le sentiment d'impunité
le plus total
et qu'on était aussi
dans la volonté
d'envoyer un signal très fort
à l'opinion publique russe,
en disant :
"On va dénazifier l'Ukraine,
"et pour commencer
"à dénazifier l'Ukraine,
il faut qu'on commence
"par extirper des cerveaux
des plus jeunes
"tout le ferment antirusse
de ceux-ci."
Et donc on s'est attaqué
aux plus vulnérables,
mais c'est pas la première fois.
-Justement, cette soi-disant
politique de dénazification
avait déjà été mise en oeuvre
après l'annexion
de la Crimée en 2014
sans que cela n'émeuve personne,
sans parler de la Tchétchénie
ni de la Syrie.
En quoi la donne a changé
et pourquoi les Occidentaux
se réveillent si tard ?
-Ca s'appelle
de la realpolitik.
Quand Poutine rase Grozny,
quand Poutine, en Syrie,
rase Alep
avec des dizaines voire
des centaines de milliers de morts,
tout le monde, - pardon,
je vais le dire de façon triviale,
mais je vais le dire quand même -
s'en fout parce que d'un côté,
c'est des Tchéchènes,
et de l'autre, des Arabes.
Là, la guerre est à nos portes...
-A deux heures.
Nous avons des Ukrainiens
et des Ukrainiennes,
comment dire, de confession
chrétienne orthodoxe,
et là, on commence à se dire :
"C'est pas possible."
Et donc,
de façon unanime,
on va se mobiliser pour dire
à Vladimir Poutine
qu'il peut pas mener cette guerre
aux portes de l'Europe.
Tant mieux si ça permet
de lutter contre l'impunité,
mais il faut pas faire preuve
d'angélisme.
Le cynisme est la règle
d'or en matière
de relations
internationales.
Monsieur Bachar el-Assad,
qui était proscrit
du banc des nations,
aujourd'hui,
la Ligue arabe le reçoit
et il revient au centre du jeu
alors qu'il a martyrisé
sa population civile.
-Michel Audiard disait :
"La justice, c'est comme la Sainte
Vierge, si on ne la voit pas
"de temps en temps,
le doute s'installe."
Beaucoup de chefs d'Etats
ont échappé à leurs juges :
Bachar el-Assad
n'a jamais été inquiété,
la Syrie n'ayant pas ratifié
le Statut de Rome.
D'autres pays puissants
se sont gardés de le signer.
Est-ce qu'on touche à la limite
de l'exercice ?
-Peut-être, mais...
Les chefs d'Etats ne sont pas
forcément chefs d'Etat à vie.
Monsieur Bachar el-Assad,
il sera, s'il n'est pas tué...
Je souhaite pas sa mort.
S'il n'est pas tué avant,
il sera un jour traduit
devant une juridiction.
Ca peut être
une juridiction française,
une juridiction
anglaise, néerlandaise,
ce sera peut-être la Cour pénale
internationale,
qui est saisie
de la situation en Syrie.
Nous avons un exemple.
Slobodan Milosevic,
il a été remis par qui ?
Il a été remis
par le gouvernement serbe.
La communauté internationale
a dit à la Serbie :
"Si vous voulez réintégrer
le concert des nations,
"qu'on vous aide
pour la reconstruction du pays,
"il va falloir
donner des gages :
"la lutte contre la corruption,
la démocratisation,
"et il va falloir qu'on s'occupe
de ceux qui ont mené cette guerre."
Et ce sont les Serbes
qui ont remis Slobodan Milosevic.
Qui aurait imaginé,
un an ou deux ans auparavant,
que le tout puissant Slobodan
Milosevic allait se retrouver
dans une cellule à La Haye ?
-Ca pourrait se passer aussi
pour Vladimir Poutine ?
Comment juger un Vladimir Poutine
alors que les instances censées
le juger dépendent
de pays qui ne reconnaissent pas
cette justice internationale ?
-En tout cas,
la Cour pénale internationale
est saisie,
ce sont des crimes imprescriptibles
et les mandats d'arrêt
ne sont pas frappés
de péremption.
Nous sommes en 2023.
Je ne sais pas ce qui se passera
en 2024, en 2025, en 2030,
mais Vladimir Poutine,
aujourd'hui,
n'est pas libre
de ses mouvements,
et je pense que s'il met
un pied dehors
et si la situation évolue
en Russie,
il y aurait le changement
de la donne
et Vladimir Poutine
sera jugé.
Peut-être, d'ailleurs,
qu'on peut imaginer
- je suis pas un politologue,
ni spécialiste de la Russie -
que pour ne pas avoir
à le déférer
devant une juridiction
internationale...
-Il soit jugé
sur le territoire russe.
Justement, est-ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer la création
d'un tribunal ad hoc,
d'un tribunal spécial habilité
viable pour juger Vladimir Poutine,
ou est-ce que seule la CPI
a la compétence de le juger ?
-Aujourd'hui, seule la CPI
a la compétence pour le juger,
mais les Nations-Unies
peuvent décider
de créer un tribunal ad hoc.
Beaucoup de juristes
demandent sa création
pour accélérer la procédure...
-Si ce n'est que beaucoup de pays
n'en veulent pas
parce qu'ils ont peur
que cet instrument
se retourne contre eux,
la France y compris.
-La France y compris.
Je ne milite pas pour la création
de ce tribunal ad hoc
parce qu'il y a une juridiction
qui existe,
c'est la Cour pénale internationale.
Si on commence à la délégitimer
à chaque fois qu'il y a un dossier,
une affaire, on va pas y arriver.
-Il y a déjà
des tribunaux nationaux
qui jugent.
A Coblence, en Allemagne,
on a jugé un militaire syrien.
Le tribunal a argué
de sa compétence
universelle.
Donc des tribunaux nationaux
peuvent se substituer
aux tribunaux pénaux
internationaux.
-C'est prévu
dans le Statut de Rome,
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une action complémentaire.
En France,
il y a encore
15 dossiers concernant
des présumés génocidaires rwandais
et qui vont être jugés.
Donc la compétence
universelle permet
aux juridictions nationales
de ces pays de juger,
sur leur territoire,
pour des crimes commis à l'étranger
des résidents de ces pays
qui se trouvent
sur le territoire français,
par exemple,
qui ont été interpellés
sur le territoire français.
Et dans la mesure où le TPIR,
le Tribunal international
pour le Rwanda, a fermé ses portes,
soit on les renvoie au Rwanda
pour qu'ils soient jugés là-bas,
soit on les juge ici.
Je rappelle également que ceux
et celles qui sont jugés
dans ces pays sur le fondement
de la compétence universelle
ne sont pas les chefs d'Etat,
mais la CPI a vocation
à juger celles et ceux
qui ont assumé
les plus hautes fonctions.
-Le crime d'agression a été retenu
pour la première fois
au procès de Nuremberg, au lendemain
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale.
Qu'est-ce qui fait défaut
aujourd'hui pour qu'un tel procès
se tienne, concrètement ?
-La volonté politique.
J'ai pas d'autre réponse.
-Aimé Césaire disait
qu'une civilisation qui ruse
avec ses principes
est une civilisation moribonde.
Ne pas juger cette agression
contre l'Ukraine reviendrait-il
à renoncer aux acquis de Nuremberg ?
-Vraisemblablement.
Et puis de toute façon,
si l'on veut reconstruire
la paix civile, si l'on veut
reconstruire la concorde,
reconstruire le savoir être
et le savoir-vivre
entre les hommes
et les femmes que nous sommes,
si l'on veut qu'il y ait
une confiance qui se restaure
entre les Etats,
quels que soient les dirigeants
qui les ont dirigés,
il faut nécessairement
lutter contre l'impunité.
L'impunité, l'injustice,
c'est une plaie béante
et de la gangrène,
et tant qu'on ne l'a pas soignée,
tant qu'on ne l'a pas traitée,
c'est impossible d'avancer.
Donc c'est une nécessité.
Si l'on veut que les standards
démocratiques soient diffusés
de façon plus unanime,
universelle et plus effective,
il faut que les criminels
soient jugés,
et tout ce qui passe
par des accords d'arrière-cuisine,
des embrassades
au nom de la realpolitik, en fait,
ça laisse une meurtrissure
indélébile dans ces populations.
Qui a vu les photos
de celui qu'on a appelé César,
ce photographe officier
qui avait pour mission
de photographier,
dans les prisons syriennes,
les tortures et les exécutions
pour documenter tous ceux
qui avaient été exécutés,
je vous assure,
si vous le voyez une fois,
vous n'en dormez plus
pendant des semaines,
et ce sont des choses
qui vous poursuivent,
je veux pas dire toute une vie,
mais c'est difficile.
Les charniers rwandais,
c'est exactement la même chose.
Pour ceux et celles
qui ont été à Boutcha,
on l'oubliera jamais.
C'est pas possible.
Donc pour que l'on puisse
vivre ensemble, avancer ensemble,
se faire confiance entre les Etats,
il faut que justice passe.
-Justement, Nuremberg,
c'est le mètre étalon
d'une justice qui passe,
qui est effective, qui est viable,
qui fonctionne ?
-C'est le mètre étalon
d'une justice
qui a fonctionné,
mais ça reste la justice aussi
des vainqueurs.
Les Etats-Unis
ont rasé Nagasaki, Hiroshima.
Ce sont des crimes de guerre
et des crimes contre l'humanité
qui ont été commis
en lâchant ces deux bombes.
Dresde a été rasée par les Alliés,
500 000 morts, que des civils.
C'est aussi, a minima,
un crime de guerre.
Ce sont les Anglais,
les Français, les Russes,
les Américains
qui ont bombardé Dresde.
On a pu juger les nazis et on a pu
juger les principaux responsables,
mais on n'a pas fait
le ménage chez nous, à l'époque.
Est-ce que c'était le prix à payer
pour que cette guerre cesse ?
Les historiens disent oui,
les populations de l'époque,
parce que c'est facile,
en 2023, de donner des leçons,
alors qu'on n'a pas vécu
la Seconde Guerre mondiale,
mais quand on regarde les choses
juste sur le plan des principes,
c'est un mètre étalon relatif.
-Ce qu'il faut dire,
c'est que vous travaillez pro bono.
Vous travaillez gratuitement
pour ces ONG, ces associations.
Est-ce que dans ces dossiers
ultra sensibles,
comme celui
contre Vladimir Poutine,
vous subissez des pressions
politiques ou diplomatiques ?
-En l'état, je n'ai subi...
Nous n'avons subi...
Parce que je travaille
pas seul,
je travaille avec des confrères
et des consoeurs.
Nous n'avons subi aucune pression,
aucune.
Je vous réponds directement.
La seule chose
que l'on doit faire
lorsqu'on traite
ce type de dossier
comme avocat ou comme avocate,
c'est d'essayer
de prendre la parole
de façon pondérée
et mesurée,
de pas raconter n'importe quoi,
d'une part.
Enfin, il ne faut pas nourrir
ou laisser nourrir de faux espoirs.
Lorsque je dis
que j'ai la conviction
que Vladimir Poutine
sera jugé un jour,
je le pense vraiment.
Lorsque j'ai dit
qu'il serait poursuivi...
C'est pas un motif de gloire
personnel, on m'a ri au nez.
Je constate qu'il y a eu
des mandats d'arrêt.
Pour avancer dans le combat
contre l'impunité
et pour la justice universelle
et internationale,
il faut avoir,
d'une certaine façon,
la foi du charbonnier.
-Justement, qu'est-ce qui vous fait
penser qu'un jour,
Vladimir Poutine sera jugé ?
C'est votre optimisme légendaire ?
-Je ne sais pas s'il est légendaire
mais en tout cas,
c'est mon optimisme,
d'une part.
D'autre part,
car c'est le sens de l'Histoire.
On ne peut pas se satisfaire
que les principaux responsables
ne soient pas jugés.
Si l'on veut, nous,
mais aussi les générations
qui viennent,
croire au fonctionnement
de la justice,
si l'on oeuvre chacun
et chacune dans ces métiers,
pour éviter que de telles choses
se reproduisent,
il faut bien qu'on se dise :
s'il y a un crime,
il y aura une poursuite,
évidemment, avec le respect
de la présomption d'innocence,
et s'il y a une déclaration
de culpabilité,
il y aura une sanction,
que ça soit Poutine
ou que ça soit le brigadier-chef
Vladimir Prigonov,
qui était à Boutcha.
-Pour vous, ces poursuites
contre Vladimir Poutine,
c'est l'engagement d'une vie ?
-Non, je vais pas dire ça
parce que...
J'ai été saisi
l'année dernière.
-Mais vous avez été aussi saisi
de l'affaire du siècle,
de l'inaction climatique
contre l'Etat français.
-Ce qui est l'engagement
d'une vie,
en tout cas pour un avocat
ou une avocate,
c'est d'utiliser le droit
comme un outil de progrès social.
Ca, c'est un engagement,
de faire en sorte
que l'on puisse,
ça peut paraître
un peu angélique ou un peu niais,
améliorer la vie au quotidien
des citoyennes et des citoyens.
-Je vais le dire
autrement.
Quand on poursuit
un Poutine pour génocide
et crime contre l'humanité,
devient-on, par la force des choses,
l'avocat de l'humanité ?
-Non.
Non, il faut
rester à sa place.
Moi, je suis avocat
au barreau de Paris.
Je traite les dossiers
avec sérieux et avec humilité.
Il faut pas se prendre
pour ce qu'on n'est pas.
Je suis un avocat lambda
qui travaille sur des dossiers
qui me sont confiés.
J'y attache
une importance particulière.
Nous sommes les avocats,
dans notre cabinet,
de la Fédération internationale
de la ligue des droits de l'homme
depuis des années,
depuis le début
des années 2000.
Nous défendons
d'autres ONG
comme RSF, MSF,
la Fondation Abbé Pierre.
-Tout ça gratuitement.
-Je vais pas revenir
là-dessus.
C'est parce qu'on veut le faire
et parce que les contentieux
ou les actions que nous menons
aux côtés de ces ONG,
de ces associations
et ces fédérations
ont des enjeux sociétaux.
Il faut utiliser
le droit,
comme d'autres utilisent
la plume,
pour faire avancer
les choses.
-Est-ce que vous avez échangé
avec l'ancien garde des Sceaux,
Robert Badinter, sur les poursuites
contre Vladimir Poutine ?
A 95 ans, il s'est lancé
dans ce combat :
traduire le dictateur russe
devant un tribunal
pour crime contre l'humanité.
-Je n'ai pas échangé avec lui.
J'ai échangé avec l'un
des auteurs de l'ouvrage.
-Robert Badinter, Bruno Cotte
et Alain Pellet ont dressé
un réquisitoire implacable,
sobrement intitulé
"Vladimir Poutine,
l'accusation."
A la fin de l'ouvrage, les auteurs
reproduisent in extenso
des discours de Vladimir Poutine.
J'imagine que ces discours
pourraient à eux seuls constituer
des éléments à charge, non ?
-Bien sûr.
Ce sont des éléments à charge.
Les vidéos enregistrées
par la télévision d'Etat russe,
qui étaient mises en ligne
sur le site officiel
du Kremlin
où l'on voit monsieur Poutine
prendre des décisions
comme commandant en chef de l'armée,
sont des éléments à charge.
Je vais même aller plus loin :
c'est une preuve.
-Emmanuel Daoud,
vous êtes un enfant d'immigrés,
diriez-vous qu'à ce titre,
vous êtes plus sensible
à la vulnérabilité
et à la fraternité ?
-Je m'attendais pas
à cette question.
Ca m'émeut beaucoup, votre question.
Ce que je sais,
c'est que je ne supporte pas
l'injustice.
Je ne supporte pas,
pour parler de notre pays,
le traitement qui est réservé
aux migrants, aux réfugiés
et aux exilés.
J'ai honte, j'ai honte
du démantèlement
de la jungle de Calais.
J'ai honte que 700 gamins
se soient
retrouvés dans une école
pendant
deux ou trois semaines
privés de tout parce qu'ils
n'avaient pas de refuge.
J'ai honte que la question
de l'immigration soit,
à ce point, instrumentalisée
par les populistes de tous poils.
Oui, j'ai honte.
Je pense que nous devrions,
pas simplement les avocats,
tout le monde, se regarder
dans une glace en disant :
"Mais franchement,
"quand on parle de solidarité
et de fraternité,
"est-ce que, vraiment,
c'est le cas en France ?"
D'ailleurs,
puisque vous parliez
de Robert Badinter,
on dit souvent :
"La France, le pays
des droits de l'homme."
Robert Badinter répond :
"Non, la France n'est pas le pays
"des droits de l'homme.
La France est le pays
"de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme."
C'est pas la même chose.
La Déclaration, c'est pas 2022.
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui,
ces droits sont respectés en France,
s'agissant
de certaines populations ?
La réponse est non.
Ca, oui, ça doit révolter
tout le monde,
quel que soit notre âge
et notre profession.
-Merci.
-Merci à vous.
SOUS-TITRAGE :
RED BEE MEDIA